gentlemen thank you all for being
present for the press conference of the
film the expendables 2
specialized units berstein west it is
with great honor and great pleasure that
I ask you to welcome
part of the team by my side  of the film part of the
cast starting with mr dolph
lundgren and arnold schwarzenegger as well
as the actor jean claude van damme and
i am sylvester stallone
here i propose to you my start
now with a first question
in the room madam hello given the
impressive cast of the  film which
brings together the best of the genre
this film it's a little bit
like an olympic games final for
you you want to know if precisely on the
set you felt a kind of
competition between you a
particular will of pasta and the other
casts of  bad exact date of
natcho waste the rumors nozay
that gives days of fort simpson tells us
that to tell the truth during filming myself
and I encourage them and at his feet and
a little each other to encourage
this competitive spirit that exists
anyway because he tells me all
the people you see here the
people who are in the film are
athletes naturally qu  'they have this
spirit of competition already in them and
so somewhere in their private life
too it's something
that is very present in their
behavior and in their
habits so and then it's true
tells us  that we all know that we are very
lucky to be actors in this kind of
film to make this kind of film it's
a it's a real chance so myself
once again during the shooting
I encourage them to  to go in this direction
and to those to raise each other a little
to be able to give the best
of themselves on the welcome
screen another question is this talent in
algeria
she puts on iphone developers
of absence of  risc group and with anna
haag opu  s cause of soul blues and life
but to make the efforts the efforts
of the work together was called the
lattois disaster of hendrix paintball and stay
tuned
the cause in external hard aubrac a
question was for sir stallone
7.7 of a tells us  that she has matured a lot
but the question is is but at the
same time in the film all the
characters that you play that you
interpret the screen well they can
dismantle a nuclear bomb very
easily on the other hand to speak with a
woman it  is already much more difficult
and why it was important to show
this kind of weakness that they have
compared to the woman in the film and
sylvester stallone tells him that a
woman anyway is something
it is  that it's someone knows
something much more complicated
than a nuclear weapon
and somewhere it shows their little
side dad sure not necessarily comfortable
in this kind of situation and when they
are in a group  when everyone c  he
characters that we see in films
are part of a group
it works it works but at the same
time when we look at their private
life their family life their life their
marriage well it's an absolute disaster there is
absolutely everything  everything is going badly and everything is
quite disastrous is really everything
works only when they are
once again in this spirit of being equipped
and somewhere this also reinforces this
expendable side, that is to say the fact
that we can in quotation marks get
rid of  from them easily well it
reinforces the spirit side of equipped it
somehow also explains all
these difficulties they have in their life
in their daily life and to the
victims another question thanks to
sir here the first ones here by year
after  i have a general question for
for the 4 what is their definition of
hero and warrior who is maybe
even where can access scotian gosford
for you what is your own definition of
may cry for you to i want what they d  o
in rock of [ __ ] want to be yes my bubble
she without witness of this regulation n was taken
out of the water by stands remains
other cause of the false mix of pass
passes
our investment in order to be bad
here life is born  in africa
if we are told that jean michaud because
you make me laugh I didn't lead manifone
meadows special magic mouse without you
gave a magic man same scene the chrono
gives way 1.12 special moves to gif momento
shine date either sends a strike from
wishes again no but definition of
heroes he parks at believe in to
something
good causse and wendel fisker in the
world even bing sky one people can fly
to something we want to protect even
if risks erdogan africa to
lackberg challenges to women for life s  he only says
a hero for him his definition of a
hero is someone who he feels
that he has a duty to two of the thirty
others in competition quite simply to
be in competition precisely to
go against this kind of  feelings
sometimes that we can have from
everyone can have of being useless of
not really having any
deep use and good for a port to go
beyond that they are going to do
something heroic in a way  to be
just copies to remember his passes and
the pac are not like someone from
someone like that on the street someone
from youtube regular from keane who
is worthless but someone who really has
do something to
change something something
profound and that's why
leverage without a doubt a lot of people
join the military a lot of people join the
military so they can
really accomplish something that
goes beyond  what life can
offer you at the start for him that's the
definition of a hero arnold
schwarzenegger answer resumes said on this
by saying that a hero for him
is someone who makes
something impossible out of something impossible
possible p  for him it's really it's at
this moment that we realize that he
has achieved something heroic in
the broad sense of the term
he takes the example in particular of nelson
mandela who said that many things
can seem impossible and are
described as being impossible to
do until someone has faced it and
that somewhere it is it is also a
challenge it is a challenge which can
be a political challenge for example
it  there were certain
political decisions the results that we have to
obtain that seem absolutely
impossible to obtain and that some
people obtain precisely
simply because they have tried that
they have succeeded in doing it but it
also works this kind of reflection
can also  adapt to the world of
sport to the world of science to the world of
cinema
of course
and it's true that there are different
types of heroes and today we are
told off shore zehnacker today we
are obviously not  there for p  talk about
politics etc.
we are here to talk about a film so
about a show and that's when we come
back to the cinematographic genre and
when we talk about heroes in this
spirit there are a lot of heroes and the
way we go  realize that they
are heroes well for example a
year and a half ago a villain a villain in the
movie and this villain set and a half
it feels like he's impossible to
beat he's absolutely impossible
he's invincible and  the hero are his
goal at that moment is to manage to
fight him and to manage to defeat him
and at that moment he did
something heroic and in the eyes of the
spectators here he is the hero c  it is
he who becomes the hero
and then it is also people who
quite simply risk their lives so
they can risk their lives for
many things for their family
for a cause for for many things
but the great advantage also in the
film  what is it that these comedians
have come to defend today  urd'hui is good
is that in relation to all that in
relation to all these all these themes
that we have to talk about heroism the
fight there is also something
very important
is humor and humor c  it's
something that sylvester stallone
does very very effectively
just to start with because he
knows the comedians he's played with very well
he decided not to show them
just on their sides very strong
very low reservations with  his oars is
also very funny and there is and
it was moreover a very
important challenge for sylvester stallone
when when we see all all
the actors who are here for example
dolph lundgren in schengen he is
someone  we see him who is very
serious who is very who is very who
is very serious who is very very
effective but he is also a
very, very funny person and that the people they
know they know well
know that know that  they funny  but to be
able to bring it to the screen in a
subtle way and at the same time that works
that works that people understand and
picks up immediately
it's a real work of director that
sylvester stallone arnold schwarzenegger
has done really very well and
somewhere he hopes  also that the public
will be able to see and
and detect in each of the actors 7
this funny side thanks to the scenarios in
particular written by sylvester stallone
and thanks to all these very
very funny little moments which make the film can
be understood and interpreted by
many public  different not only
an American or German or
French audience but not really all
people because we must not forget that
arnold schwazenegger tells us that he
himself did not participate in test screenings
of the film to see how people
reacted but  anyway he knows
he feels he knows very well that the film is going to
be thanks to this
humorous dimension will be understood and applied  praised
by people all over the world
whether in china in france or in
any corner of the world and
compared to that jean claude van damme says
that his position is slightly
different because in the film he
is  the villain cde is the low
end and so is him it was up end
this tale his heroic side was
finding someone something
to fight against and he tells us that playing
will be there for sylvester stallone
it  was really a
great thing because sylvester
stallone found all those magical little moments
for proof of being able to
really shine in quotes
on screen he really gave
every comedian in the movie
every comedian in the movie not
to  to be in quotes a bit drowned in
the tent in all the casting certainly
prestigious but but really for
each person to have the possibility
of expressing themselves to shine on the screen at some
point and each in quotes
c  everyone has a chance
and so all the actors in the film
had this little moment when they were able to shine
like
that one after the other and it was
something wonderful and besides jean
claude van damme tells us something
great who without a doubt in any
case with a cast like this will not be
renewed on the big screen
and finally he tells us in relation to the
definition of the hero for him and well he
is someone who lives certainly does
heroic things who  in this specific case,
for example, has to fight, but he is
also someone who is afraid to fight
and who was not afraid to
show that he is afraid to be baptized he is
afraid there is he  there is apprehension
but he will still fight to be able to
accomplish these heroic things and there
it was a little bit the different
definitions of the word hero for the
actors here today
another question in the front row yes
I will make it short
you will have to
keep yourself in f for decades  elm
you can't really let yourself
go are there not times
when it's particularly exhausting and
restrictive in the states
in short a title that matters in fact
when I myself go to train game
I always hesitate  between these are
English expressions so it's an
approximate translation between between
super good shots so rest me a
good broom and so we were kings of
leon fate va salvage July 10 yes their
briois tag and we know how do so is
why can't we will i am the death knell of this
point
in fact
sylvester stallone is just saying the
question we always ask
when when we have to train and
stay in shape and stay in good
physical condition and be able to continue  to do this
kind of thing for a
long time it's the pleasure is what the
pleasure is worth compared
to the pain also the pain the
difficulty that one has precisely to stay
in shape
in this kind of shape and it  tells
us that  ur him in any case for all the
people who participated in this film the
answer is clearly yes
it's the game worth the effort
because of course it's difficult of course
not paying much attention to what you
eat  training a lot whether
in the weight room in the
gym is obviously something
difficult but we derive real
pleasure from it and we continue to derive
real pleasure from it and and somewhere it is
also this discipline  in which he
finds pleasure and he tells us that
today he and his
teammates know their bodies very very
well they know exactly how to do
they know the right gestures and the
right methods and the right techniques
so they know how to do but that
takes time a lot of time
years before really knowing
the best thing to do the right
the right methods but the right
gestures and here are my but once again
tells us the answer  is yes if the game is
worth the candle
but yes it is also very very
difficult another question in the
room
it is about offenses training and weekend
despite a huge success it is a sequel
mainly used in the fall
it is  a little less here abs van
nistelrooy makeover kassianov we
look towards yang
we need is like few jennings at this we go
antivirals difficult from riot games to big
ship n is either thrust three goals and
10 and doazit
they don't have to  12:30 p.m.
but alice b American AIDS drive
until Monday 6 at her heels at 10 best
buy you don't call yes or Vaudois
and Nov 6
alice best buy
the high place when we when we
train we don't  does
training to be able to stay strong
stays and stays in good
physical shape for a very long time
in fact it very quickly becomes a
real addiction it's something to
which he himself tells us for example
that he cannot imagine spending a
week  without training  without going to the
gym for the gym to
train and somewhere he tells us
that all these roles that they did it
also helped a lot to
promote fitness training
training taking care of himself
he  tells us that a few years ago in
fact it was impossible to find a
gym in some hotels
some hotels in africa for example
or elsewhere and today we have we
obviously have gyms in all
the hotels and there  tells us that sometimes there
is even sports equipment sometimes
even of a very high level very
sophisticated in the rooms
directly so somewhere he is
quite happy to see this evolution
to be able to continue to be in shape
and take care of himself and and he  says for
him sport is something
almost natural it's like when you
eat it's like when you sleep it's
like when you make love it
's something all that somewhere that
can everything everyone  s these things
are things that can be perceived
as training taking care of yourself
ccc practicing and it remained encouraging at the
top and but for him he does not read that it is
not at all something
constraining c1  it's a lifestyle and
it's his in particular
he tells me that for example this morning
they took bicycles six bicycles they went
to visit Paris like that by bicycle
quite simply to be able to spend
time they don't get used to  they
did not ask themselves the question, was it
difficult to ride a bike,
no, on the contrary, they went to visit
paris like that in the morning and they saw
this magnificent city by bike,
which is a very pleasant way to
discover paris  and a few pearls united
when they are young when he sleeps
when he takes his breakfast
there is no particular discipline
to do these things quite
natural and good for him to train
to play sports and to keep in shape
it's the same  it's something
natural in any case it's something
that wouldn't occur to him to do
without this office things and jean
claude van damme adds that at the same
time it's true that when we
look at them we see on their faces
that let's say that they have suffered in
quotes that it has been difficult
sometimes to train for all
these years to be able to stay on
top physically but somewhere they
have they need that it's
something, that's a real need on the rise
and they don't take that at all as
a particular constraint and it's
true that jean claude didn't read
television in particular sometimes when we were
asked this kind of question,
it's difficult and it's good we want
to answer yes it's true it's
difficult it's restrictive but at the
same time no for them it's not that
difficult because it was
easy somewhere this  that they like to
do that it's really part of their
p  personality and their daily routine
so he tells us that it was not
very difficult
on the other hand does he sometimes remember
on set arriving on time at the time
of shooting sometimes it was a
little bit  more difficult but
training and restaurants pubs and
restaurants but obviously with the
ring is always very close to the hand
but in any case in any case in
training doing sports it's
really part of their lifestyle and
dolph lundgren moreover reminds us of
something he had said earlier
and which I had not translated
which was that in a few
minutes earlier what in a few
minutes earlier from  elsewhere he has to
go to the gym of this end word he has to
he has to go to the gym to
train he's going to go there is ilahi
looking forward to it and jean claude ended
by presenting some drawings  made
by the actors present here who
are also sold at auction  es
in some time of the efforts of the
drawings a wonderful that you will be able to
discover in the gallery of georges 5
no doubt in a few days
here and ended this
press conference is over thank you very much it's
a cube and the  matches